vi aspettate io faccio un intro bene non
lo farò
mi avete detto voi di giocare questo io
non so che cosa sto per andare a giocare
appena l'ho visto che mi avete
consigliato ho detto vabbè mela state
consigliando non so da quanto non ci ha
voluto giocare perché lo considerava
troppo uguale troppo simile al this land
e dopo un po un po this land ero dopo un
bel po di slider scoccia dato che
continuate a consigliare meno e non ha
idea di che cosa sia magari poi non
c'entra niente uno slider però mamme
lamentazione sembra abbastanza simile
non volevo giocare poi perché mi
sembrava troppo uguale a splendere
invece a quanto pare non è proprio
uguale al land non sono a chi comandi
c'erano scritti prima ma io ovviamente
non leggo mai niente come quando stato
un videogame non fate il tutorial e non
sapete come si gioca
ditelo che l'avete fatto tutti almeno
una volta
c'è questa che è tutto fuorché una luce
dopo una cosa stupida
ok chi è questo ma quel quella fare lì e
sarebbe come come si chiama ha un nome
si chiama lui i rei
potrei sbagliare perché non ignari che
cosa sia non mi piace questa musica
ok basta basta no no no no no questo no
non ho seriamente basta
no no no no no
ci rinuncio seriamente questo è
eccessivo bastardo ti posso tirare un
cazzotto no lui sono presentate ragazzi
no perché non mi fa mi inquieta sto
gioco perché non capisco allora
anzitutto non so chi è ma poi ti spunta
in una maniera che inquieta abbastanza
ma sta ferma e normale cioè se io mi
muovo tipo lo guardo mi fa passare
grazie parla mi guarda me no vabbè ma
ragazzi questo è veramente eccessivo
perché poi ce ne sono di più direi che
ho visto che ce n'erano due io non
scaricato noi due non so qual è questo
si chiama questo so qual è ancora st
musica cos'è che successo
sono stato teletrasportato all'inizio
bene dicevo ce ne sono due di drake
questo è hostel l'altro non mi ricordo
come si chiama
non so qual è il primo non so quale
secondo me lo ha scaricato semplicemente
perché l'avete detto voi però mi mi
inquieta veramente tanto questo è ciò
che un atmosfera diversa se la sono
studiato molto bene
diciamo questo è un vicolo cieco no non
mi piace non mi far tornare indietro
se infatti tornano indietro perfetto
vale la regola this then there mai
guardarsi dietro spero di no sì raga
tipo lowes lander non puoi fare due
passi che ti appare dietro invece quasi
ti giri non non compare subito almeno
credo me lo devo aspettare
no ma se spengo la luce aiuta magari non
mi trova ok a luce spenta mi pare che
però non vedo niente ragazzi
ok soltanto che per vedere la luce
spenta mi devo avvicinare perché non si
vede niente
e se mi apparisse adesso sarebbe una
cosa come fuori vado però non vedete
niente voi così è infatti già vedo a
stento io figuriamoci poiché già youtube
cioè annerisce video che la metà basta
ok non c'è niente faccia silenzio perché
non si sa mai che mi senta il microfono
va bene
salve
c'è qualcuno
ok
ragazzi ma c'era uno scopo a parte a
parte prendere infarti sto gioco c'era
uno scopo serve a qualcosa che cosa devo
fare cos'è qual è cosa qual è il mio
obiettivo in studio si passa si passa si
passa
cos'è un tavolo da biliardo ragazzi
facciamo progressi che si fa una
partitina bello mi fa piacere per
trovato un tavolo da biliardo
diciamo che non si annoia il tipo
qualunque cosa esso sia non si annoia
ho preso una strada completamente random
destra sinistra destra perché vede una
luce un ok perfetto credo di aver
trovato il bagno ok
no no ragazzi dall'inizio no no
dall'inizio no dall'inizio no vi prego
dall'inizio no non lo accetto è troppo
ok per haga faccio un bel taglio fino a
quel punto se riesco a ri arrivarci
perché dall'inizio veramente è oscena
come cosa ma qua ce l'ho passato
aspettato un attimo nostri così non me
li ricordo va bene o reparto doccia
ok comincero passato invece no non
faccio un taglio perché evidentemente
c'è un posto che però non avevo visto ma
[Musica]
sparisci ok ragazzi la magia nei
videogiochi horror ancora non mi ha
abbandonato
l'unica cosa è che
non lo so io quando mi spavento troppo
non trovo le parole per andare avanti
quindi oddio cos'è mazzo mazzo questa è
veramente grossa una istanza non è che
abbia tanta compagnia quindi è un po
strano che abbia tutti sti tavoli però
contento lui contenti gli ospiti poi chi
è che viene ospite da su cui io non ci
vengo tavolo per due no me ne vado
ne vado no perché il bello che ci sono
delle volte in cui ti compare propri in
faccia lì è veramente
inquietante prosegue buio ragazzi perché
non vorrei trovarmi un avanti adesso ok
siamo appunto di prima
qui e ci ha fatto una brutta fine prima
non intendo farcela adesso ok ok
attiva allo scarico voglio uscire di qua
ok va bene
non si attiva
io proseguo ok anche qua perfetto vicolo
cieco è anche co preso uno
farmi tirare lo scarico ti prego
va bene torni indietro ragazzi dunque
assoluto sono abbastanza avanti cioè
c'ero arrivato prima dove dopo due ore
di camminata c'ero arrivato e poi sono
morto quindi devo andare di qua credo
spero di non morire adesso no ma lui è
tanto buone non spunta sempre
ok raccolta volo da biliardo ero
arrivato di la prima quella è la strada
vecchia ok questa è l'unica strada
[Musica]
le strade chiuse le odio ragazzi no
perché veramente non capisco altri
tavoli
no quando c'ero passato invece ok era
questa la strada ma perché tutte le
altre l'ho già viste ok non devo morire
ad essa manderò
qua ce l'ho già passato prima non sono
altri barili fortunatamente
cos'è
cos'è ho preso una pagina era qui
ho preso una pagina che non è tipo
quello dell'islanda cosa devo fare ora
posso aprirla e leggere no non mi piace
devo tornare indietro forse ok
ho preso una pagina tipo quelle this
then there tipo non so cosa era una nota
e ora probabilmente devo tornare
indietro credo anche perché non c'è
niente altro da fare
ci provo torna indietro sono indietro
torno indietro
torna indietro quale strada non lo so
questa ok forse devo tornare alla porta
principale ragano non lo so però presumo
di sì anche perché non c'è niente da
fare è l'unica l'unico oggetto con cui
sono riuscito interagire oltre st torcia
stupida è stato proprio quello è stata
quella pagina di di prima quindi presumo
che ora debba tornare indietro
se riesco a ritrovare la strada
ovviamente o no questo il biliardo
va bene devo devo tornare dall'altra
parte c'è una strada di qua
ok sto girando stavo girando in tondo
ragazzi ero di nuovo al biliardo ok
dovrebbe essere quella ragazza per
tornare indietro
ce la posso fare dai
ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare devo soltanto devo
soltanto tornare indietro tutto qua non
sarà tanto difficile però non so che
strade per chiudere
non so che sto ragazzi veramente e più
dispersivo l'islanda sto gioco cioè non
so proprio dove andare
ok ok ci dovrei essere forse non vorrei
fare un file ma dovrei essere tipo a
buon punto fail era l'altra ragazzi c'è
la mano sinistra quella che uso che
premere i tasti per muovermi che mi sta
tremando giuro
ok ok
di qui
ci sono passato no
dovrebbe essere tipo dovrei esserci
vicino nostri barili non me li ricordo
che palle ma dove sto andando a finire
ragazzi ragazzi c'è da due ore troppo
silenzio non sento niente
ok adesso sono ripartite le voci per la
prima non senti di giorno sentivo niente
lamp è ancora più inquietante bari o
questo è l'inizio ok
l'ho riconosciuto
va bene dovrebbe essere questo se non
sbaglio
se non sbaglio dovrebbe essere qui a
destra
ok
perfetto primo stesso riuscito
fantastico ragazzo l'ho fatta a un certo
punto veramente non ci credevo perché
c'è veramente è pesantissimo sto gioco
vi lascio il link per scaricarlo in
descrizione vabbè comunque ragazza vi è
piaciuto video lasciate mi piace
lasciato momento qui sotto
diventate fan sulla pagina di facebook
che ci vedeva prossimo video bella
ragazzi